all right chris well thank you for that
well a trip to the arts district in
downtown las vegas will soon cost you a
little more the city is set to install
parking meters at the end of this month
rates will vary between a dollar or two
an hour now you can see the impacted
areas highlighted in pink green and
yellow right there on the map joe muller
joining us live there with what people
are saying about this joe
christian well you know when you come
down here and it's during the busy hours
it's not necessarily easy to park but
right now it is free you just pull up
get out of your car and walk around
people we talked to who work down here
say they're happy with the idea of any
parking meters to pay for a parking
garage others were not too thrilled
about the idea
soon there will be 64 meters with
monthly rates available for employees
the money will go towards a new parking
garage you will be able to pay using a
debit or credit card those who work in
the arts district say it will be worth
it in the long run and make more spaces
available as they are metered it'd
probably be a good idea just because
then we'd be able to find parking or
even if we're able to
pay for our parking i wouldn't mind
because at least i'd be able to come to
work on time art district regulars
gordon vallo and cade dessa weren't too
thrilled to hear about the meters it
makes the area feel a little bit more
inviting you know when you just can
stroll in and cruise into a spot not to
worry about having the right change on
you or forgetting to pay or you know
worrying about getting a ticket and that
kind of thing so you know it's a little
bit of a bummer but it's not going to
stop you from coming
another live look here at main street in
the arts district well there already are
meters in downtown near fremont street
they start to go in here in the our
district at the end of the month the
city says
the location for that parking garage is
not set but they have expect
construction to be underway by 2024.
reporting in the arts district this
evening joe muller live welcome
all right joe thank you for that so we
want to ask we want to know we want to
ask you what you think about the plan do
you agree or disagree when on our
twitter poll and so far an overwhelming
majority of you you can see right there
say no you disagree kirsten